just enough further loss leave us no
control it's disturbing bomba so concise
with my Nicole you must know when B plan
B teen gay from Berlin rapper rapper now
in his early 30s George Boateng has been
making music for about eight years in
the early 1980s his father emigrated to
Germany with my mom and my dear dad
comes from from Africa Ghana the writing
is small why is that here from Accra
it's not intentional in went to
university worked hard his debut album
is titled give oxen of patong a title
that makes reference to the concrete
thats everywhere in vetting a role in
district with a gritty reputation boa
tank doesn't live here anymore but he
still calls it home
they're letting dynastar much all
situations advice dating has this sense
of togetherness and as possible the
street had maybe 500 families and you
know eighteen eighty five percent of
them and everyone knew your family it
was good strasse blitz casa open bizarre
face to the face my mom too sweet pea
valium unlock code for the Jeep to the
heart of the hard part for the end is
sweet BTE the station's unwitting that's
what you see in districts like bedding
the Whitesburg and my cone it's that
kind of family feeling today the boa
tank family are celebrities embedding
George boa tangs brothers are world
famous footballers kevin-prince played
for top-level clubs and Ghana's national
team in 2014 Jerome played on the German
world champion team in his youth George
was a talented footballer but he swapped
his football boots for a microphone we
spin him through this desk last lap
tannins feeling fixin up on these stops
awesome fans in houma LA Ink Spots a
toast in part they part of it it open
block the Dalton positive enzymes
honestly shocked more savvy that some
vista marcela me lonesome leggings among
you Monica know we always wanted
recognition young we have that now each
in our own field which mean that's all
I'm heading in a good direction and I'm
grateful for the positive feedback I've
been getting which makes it even more
fun fossil
but the path here wasn't easy George boa
ting spent eight months in custody
awaiting trial then he turned his life
around married had two children and
started his rap career although his
father left the family when he was a
young boy boa Tang was still shaped by
his ganea news
the essence Axela been conserved the
first six years of childhood are the
most important and my father shaped me
in those years plus Ghanians enjoy
experimenting with music and have a
different lifestyle from the German ace
it's no mother to build a chisel George
Boateng always had to deal with racism
today he lets insult bounce off him but
in the summer of 2015 he was shocked in
a talk show the Bavarian politician you
Joaquim Herman described see Roberto
Blanco as a wonderful Negro a statement
that made headlines open public amudha
in the audience and guests didn't react
not on behalf of us Africans of black so
to speak or about the injustice that
kind of denigrating language about
another race don't ask me or other
people Germany needs two outs itself why
this kind of thing can be said on TV
definition and in Duncan
for club because it but words aren't
enough for George Boateng he's planning
a foundation to help socially
disadvantaged people he's got new rhymes
in the works too and more than enough
material